cyberpunk 2077 rating leaks Deadly
Premonition and destroy humans get
release dates and GameSpot has a big
charity event going on this summer I'm
chastity and this is your safe safe for
Tuesday April 28th one rating for
cyberpunk 2077 has leaked and it's 18
plus only Brazil's ratings board briefly
released its classification for
cyberpunk 2077 before removing it but
someone grabbed a screenshot and posted
it on reddit it's rated 18 + go figure
which is the same as the US has M for
Mature and Europe's Peggy 18 as for
reasons why the list includes extreme
violence crime drug use nudity blood
gore and a whole bunch of other mature
content this comes as no surprise right
but my favorite bit is that one of cyber
Pugsley designers reacted to the leak in
a tweet saying we don't around next up
deadly premonition - and destroy humans
now have release dates did you hear that
Zak
Deadly Premonition - a blessing in
disguise is coming exclusively to switch
on July 10th for $50 it's both a prequel
and a sequel to the first game jumping
between the current investigation headed
up by special agents Davis and Jones in
present-day Boston while also revisiting
past memories of my boys special agent
Francis York Morgan and Louisiana
Destroy All Humans is a remake of the
ps2 and original Xbox game adding
content that was cut from the original
it's coming to ps4 Xbox one and PC on
July 28th priced at $39.99 in the US
there's also a 149 $99 DNA collector's
edition which includes a crypto and cow
figurine keychain six lithographs
anti-stress toy and in-game crypto skins
then there's the crypto 137 Edition
which has the same stuff except there's
a larger crypto figurine and backpack
that edition cost 399 99 yes really are
you gonna check out either of those
games I'm pretty excited about Deadly
Premonition - and if you've never played
the first game and you love twin peaks'
I highly recommend it this is excuse me
a damn fine cup of coffee next Google
stadia is adding a bunch of games
the latest stadia connect was packed
first pub G surprise launch so that's
available right now Pro members get the
Pioneer Edition which includes the
survivor pass cold front and an
exclusive skin set second stadia pro
members are getting three other games in
May
steam world heist and the turn tests
arrive on May 1st and zombie
me for dead war is coming later in the
month octopus traveler hits stadia this
week and finally there are more games
coming in the future including some big
EA titles Star Wars Jedi fallen order in
the fall and Madden NFL and FIFA in the
winter
have you tried stadia if not do any of
these games make you want to give it a
shot
but Lego Lord of the Rings games have
returned to steam Lego the Lord of the
Rings and Lego The Hobbit disappeared
from Steam and the 360 and ps3 digital
stores in 2019 with no explanation it
might have been a licensing issue as
other Lord of the Rings games like
shadow of Mordor and shadow war didn't
go away thankfully those two Lego games
are back on steam again with no
statement about their disappearance it's
not clear if they're back on 360 and ps3
yet my personal favorite Lego game was
marvel super heroes but what's your
favorite Lego game and finally get ready
for GameSpot to play for all charity
event III might not be happening this
year but we've got you covered this
summer GameSpot is going to be hosting
play for all a multi week event that is
going to be the best place for you to
get all the latest gaming news features
interviews and live streams not only
that but we're also partnering with
Direct Relief to raise funds for health
care workers risking their lives daily
on kovat 19 relief efforts we'll have
over 100 hours of awesome content that
will feature the GameSpot team as well
as friends from across the industry
including the Giant Bomb crew kind of
funnies Greg Miller no clips Danny
O'Dwyer and many more will be announcing
over the coming weeks we hope you'll
join us to celebrate gaming and raise
money for a great cause and we'll have
more details for you soon and that's
your safe safe for Tuesday I'm chastity
and can find me over on GameSpot
universe at youtube.com slash GameSpot
universe or on Twitter at chasity
underscore V for all the latest news
stick with GameSpot
[Music]